[Music]
confidence is your best accessory
there is nothing else you need if you
the only thing you need to wear well is
your confidence
confidence truly is the key to
getting ahead in life if you believe in
yourself the world will believe in you
because perception is reality
i don't think confidence is something
that
you are born with i don't think
confidence is it's a skill set
and i had no confidence growing up as a
child
i had very low self-esteem
i was a kid full of fear insecurities
somebody who had very low self-esteem
didn't believe in myself at all
the only thing that i knew that i had
was the ability to work bloody damn hard
and that's the only thing that i did
confidence is something i taught myself
over the years i started becoming okay
with who i am i became the best version
of me
and then i sort of said i'm okay you
know i'm all right
your flaws are fine
no one is perfect none of us we all have
bad days we're all gonna feel like [ __ ]
sometimes you're all gonna have bad days
and that's fine
we have this crazy standard especially
with the internet where everything has
to be perfect all the time and we have
to look perfect or to behave perfect we
have to say the right things everyone
screws up and that's all right
laugh through it don't take yourself too
seriously and make sure that you don't
live for someone else's validation
it's your validation
that you need
be yourselves guys it's great to be you
whatever you might want to be
that is the best version of you so you
drop stuff around or you are clumsy and
you're a klutz but
it's you
and that's what makes you special
we are going through our problems as a
world right now because that's what we
do because we put people in boxes
because we stereotype because we say
everyone who's like this will be like
that but not in my experience
nothing is a straight line
and we need to stop looking at the world
like that
diversity shouldn't even be a
conversation it should be normal
when we look around this room there's
not one kind of person i don't even see
one kind of person in one row
and that's our normal
we've forgotten that eventually we're
all human
it's this one little planet that we have
which in this big universe is really
tiny
so we should stop giving ourselves so
much importance and saying oh well
you're better than me or i'm better than
you we all are basically humanity and
let's like go back to that and bring
compassion and kindness into beauty and
not be so hard on ourselves or other
people
in life you know there are moments when
you stop and ask yourself
how did i get here like why am i
standing here
and i find myself going back to the
beginning
back to my roots
i was born to incredible parents
amazing parents
both my my parents were very progressive
in their mindsets especially coming from
a country at that time which india was
which was a little bit like this you
know a woman's life sort of
ends when she gets married because after
that yeah you can think about
progressive families will tell you yeah
you can achieve whatever but your
milestone is to get married my mother
still says she's like you know you get
married the day you find someone who
will appreciate how hard you have worked
to get where you are who will appreciate
the sacrifices you made and that's the
man you will get married to and if you
don't doesn't matter
we're in the world of science can still
have babies
and i was like what kind of mom says
that
but the idea was the philosophy behind
it that it didn't define me
and it's so important for us to be able
to empower each other
in everyday life we don't have to
conquer the world you don't have to be
the only person who reaches space like
you don't have to have crazy wild
ambitions you just have to find your
power and to say that oh i can do this
too
i don't have to
create like this crazy opportunity for
me to thrive you can thrive in anything
you choose just have to find that
confidence within yourself
life can never be safe
and if it's safe
it's not worth living
it really isn't
you have to take risks risks are so
important in evolution
playing it safe
yeah you can have an existence but
you'll never be someone who's a
trailblazer
the world is your oyster if i a girl
from a small town like barely
from an army officer's family middle
class background can today be a movie
star giving an inspirational speech to
you today be
debuting in america as an international
pop star can't any one of you do it
if i can do it
you can do it right
the world is your oyster
finding our own confidence no one is
going to give that to you no one is
gonna tell you here's an opportunity
go make something of yourself you're
gonna do it for you
i just love growing like i said i think
growing is a very important thing and
when i was very young i started working
when i was 17 years old
[Music]
you need to be responsible for your
finances and be financially independent
and that kind of really stuck with me
i just
love what i do and i'm good at it and i
love the ability to wake up in the
morning and say oh my god i get to go to
work i mean how many people
in their lifetimes do a job
that they love doing most people do it
for survival
kitchen we need to feed our families we
need to survive but to wake up with you
know my my feet and my fingers tingling
and say wow i have this to do i have
that to do today
and
it's an amazing feeling and i don't take
it for granted
i'm a high achiever i've always been a
high achiever i'm someone who
is goal oriented i i like challenges i
like growth i like evolution i like
knowledge so when you put all of those
things combined i have a lot more i want
to do
i've had multiple things that haven't
worked out in my life i mean i i just
don't talk about them i'm not someone
who
rests on my failures i believe that they
are natural part of life and failure
will happen to every single person and
what you do after failure that makes you
the person that you will become
you know i've always said that i'm
ambitious and i i have that's my sense
of purpose is my drive is my
contribution to the arts
that's where i feel like i'll have most
purpose and you know that's just my
quest is always that to push the
envelope
i don't really have regrets but i have
to say i think
my biggest achievement i feel is
honestly
the ability to get over my fears
i'm hugely emotional and i get affected
by a lot of things and i know i come
across as this tough sassy witty thing
and but i do think that is a big part of
keeping myself protected
um and surviving i've always had to do
it for myself there's not been anyone
who's held a safety net for me in all
the decisions that i've taken so i think
my biggest achievement is
to trust my feet to trust my legs to
trust my instinct and say even if i fall
it's okay it'll be my mistake
there's only one you
okay because there's no one like you
and i don't mean the superfluous
superficial parts
i'm talking about the core of you who
you are inside your values your beliefs
your flaws and once you understand
who really that person is
you would have made taken the first step
in finding your unique self and that is
the best version of you who am i really
most often we don't allow ourselves the
ability to dream beyond
our imagination we don't allow ourselves
to think about the future because we are
afraid of change we are afraid to move
away from what is familiar
either that or sometimes you know we are
too rigid to let our dreams evolve
loosen up
you know shake it off a little bit
change is the only constant thing in
life and you are never too old or never
too experienced to learn something new
believe that you have everything already
as your brahmastra in your will
to be able to be and achieve your dreams
be fearless
funny thing aren't these opportunities
they don't come very often
they come far and few in between
but when they do do we recognize them
our job is to recognize them and make
the most of them i look back on all the
things that i've done and i marvel at
the opportunities that came my way
more like the universe sort of guiding
me towards these opportunities all i had
to do was recognize them and make sure i
worked so hard that i squeezed every
drop out of these opportunities
this ladies and gentlemen is called
drive it's called ambition
be greedy
be greedy for your ambitions be hungry
for it don't live on someone else's
benchmarks
i've always believed that you have to
take risks calculated educated risks
to evolve because if you've not truly
explored the full extent of your
possibilities you'll always remain
stagnant
excellence is the pursuit of my life in
anything that i do my ambition gives me
purpose and i think purpose is very
important in life you have to have a
sense of purpose you whatever that might
be it could be your children it could be
your family it could be your career it
could be anything
i think my purpose is the pursuit of
excellence in anything that i do i don't
like doing anything less than perfect i
want them to say that i left behind a
legacy
i want my kids to feel like you know
proud to say that that's our mom i want
people to say that i made a dent in my
art in entertainment in my profession
i think people confuse discipline with
like punctuality sometimes but that's
not what discipline is discipline is
being prepared discipline is riaz
discipline is training discipline is
learning discipline is knowing that if
i'm going to do a job i'm going to give
it my 120 otherwise i'm not going to do
it
one mistake can cause a big big
butterfly effect
learn to be like what
adaptable fit into any vessel have a
sense of calm have a sense of patience
but ambition is extremely important and
i don't just say this to girls i say
this to boys and girls just everyone who
wants to be able to have a purpose in
life have an ambition have the guts to
find your glory
[Music]